I'm Nancy Odell and ET is on the
carpet how is it with all the intensity
of the competition Dancing with the
Stars is a ton of fun it's way more
intense than I expected like no joke I'm
like icing my body every day but I love
it it's it's really cool yeah he's doing
so well we have the Jive this week and
his legs are killing him but we've got a
really fullon routine so it's going to
be
good so are you excited for tonight yeah
very excited looking for so is this your
first kid choice or you've been before
no I've been to a few been to a few in
the past and throughout all any of those
have you ever been slimed um I've been
slimed back in Australia for one of them
but I'm getting I uh may be getting
slime tonight do you want to or are you
trying to get away from it um it's not
ideal but you know whatever happens
[Music]
happens
oh